ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show our final Audio Only episode
ever
is that a lie
but it is the the tour is over we're
back in our studio
um in America soon but we're here today
from the lovely city of Brisbane
Australia by the Steve Irwin Zoo uh you
know him the crocodile hunter who died
tragically when he was uh
what do you say harpooned or what what
did he he got what it went up under his
rib cage into his heart and they stuck
him a a uh what what do I want to say
here I want to say a praying mantis but
that's not what did it well there's a
manta ray and then there's a stingray
manta ray or Stingray which one of the
Rays
got Steve Irwin conservationist
Australian Legend his family keeps his
name
it was uh it was a stingray Barb and
that was uh the Great Barrier Reef
outside Port Douglas
that's where we're going
defending our trip a few days to go to
see the beautiful oldest rain forest in
the world
right where Steve Irwin uh met his
untimely tragic demise at the hands of a
stingray
and his family carries on his legacy and
nothing's come out about Steve Irwin
this isn't Jimmy Savile we don't have
any problems here Steve Irwin was a
conservationist who cared about the
animals
and that's why Whitney Cummings my
friend Whitney [ __ ] stand-up comedian
when me and you go to a lovely Open
Range Zoo It's never enough for the
animal freaks by the way it's never
enough for these sick [ __ ]
anything less than animals coming in
their bed at night and [ __ ] them
makes them unhappy if the animals are in
cages they're unhappy which I get
but if you put the animals on a big
range they don't like it either
so we post a photo of me and you feeding
kangaroos at the werribee Open Range Zoo
and Whitney Cummings
uh animal Advocate or just you could
leave off the word advocate
comments on my Instagram and goes
welcome to the dark side
because she her contention is that all
of the animals are drugged
in those uh
zoos safaris they're all drugged
and they're being tortured on a daily
basis that is her contention
I don't know if that's true I don't
believe that I met a lot of people
including that guy Paul that love these
animals and are caring for them and are
bringing them back from the brink of
Extinction
and the Animals didn't seem drugged
I also don't think it's morally wrong to
give them a pick-me-up
if they wanted a pick-me-up how drugged
is humanity I mean if an animal needs a
little get up and go
I don't see a problem with that but
Whitney's constantly on the animals
you're on drugs the animals right you
know who I think is on drugs but the the
point is that this this uh incessant
shaming and attacking of the zoo
industry I can't get behind
I can't get behind it not with the
people that I've met that deeply care
about the animals
from what I've observed in my five to
ten minute interactions with these
people
in the three to four minutes that I have
spent talking to these people and I
won't ever speak to them again
but in those three minutes
they did not hit an animal in front of
me he didn't punch a koala bear
we didn't walk in and the koala bears
are drugged up anyway they eat the
leaves they sleep 20 hours a day they
don't care where they sleep
let them sleep somewhere that's gonna
make a little money
they don't care you leave them in the
wild they just get torched because of
that fire
I hope that fire doesn't ruin any of
this rainforest trip I hope I gotta be
honest I don't want to see ruins here so
I want to be and we're staying in a very
LA and it was very important for me when
I visit a natural area is luxury that's
the first thing because I don't really
care about nature and I don't want to
really be near it in a way where it
could impact me negatively in any way
my main concern is luxury
I want the animals insects to know that
we are the boss
and in some of these Expeditions like
when I was younger I wanted to go to the
Brazilian Amazon I've always wanted to
like go to the Amazon River because
there are great animals the sloth the
Anaconda the black uh Panther the
bottlenose dolphin many uh parrots they
have a great place called the meeting of
the waters where the Rio negro and the
real Salome meet one is a color of
Nestle Quick chocolate milk the other is
the color of like a dark Brew espresso
and they I think or maybe it's reddish
maybe it's more reddish they slam up
against each other and because of the
silt gradient in the water they don't
mix
it's like one of a I don't know if it's
one of the wonders of the world yeah I'm
right it's one of the I don't think it's
one of the wonders of the world but it
is an amazing thing to see and I've
always wanted to see it
but you need a lot of inoculations you
need like 19 vaccines because you can
still get leprosy in Brazil which is not
uh fun
also I mean you know
that's why Americans are going to Brazil
I mean you I mean forget it I mean look
at what with the coveted vaccine that
was a big you know
how great would it be if just Rogan had
a guy on telling people why not to take
the leprosy vaccine
you can get off and leprosy if you're
not fun
but I always wanted to go to Brazil when
I was younger I go I want to go camping
I want to do uh I want to you know but
as I get older I realize that it is
important to be dominant over the
creatures and the landscape it is and
and it's Western and I'm a Westerner and
I'm unashamed of civilization and if you
don't like Civilization you can [ __ ] off
like all these people in Melbourne it
put narm or narn or whatever it is which
is the original indigenous name for the
land and they put that in their [ __ ]
dating app profile
and they think that's gonna [ __ ] that
means something cut it out cut it out
I'm a Westerner I'm not ashamed of it
I'm not marching into the capital but
I'm also like what's important to me on
a trip
that involves nature is that it is very
that it involves nature it is not
centered around nature
because nature like Woody Allen had a
great line I am too with nature like for
me it's like
you know the woman said to me what kind
of expeditions because this hotel wants
to plan the Expeditions that you go on
are you interested in hiking I said well
not really
but we want to go to the the the ice
cream shop the daintree creamery because
it's famous for making ice creams out of
tropical fruits
so I said arrange that
she goes well I don't know if that's
really an expedition I said well that's
the Expedition today so arrange that get
the driver and get us in the car to the
[ __ ] Creamery and we'll take a river
cruise and we'll look at the crocodiles
and a few things and we'll do some light
hiking maybe jump in a swimming hole
but again the main goal for me here is
to be really impressed by the hotel
not so much to Nick yes the nature is
going to be breathtaking
but the hotel is important to me I want
to feel safe I want to feel cared for I
want to know that if animals threat me
at all they will be killed on the spot
ditto people
I want to feel like an American
traveling abroad I want to feel like I
have total dominance over the natural
landscape I am uninterested in any
spiritual they go well it's a very
spiritual area well I'll be the judge of
that and I have no interest in that
yes it is the world's uh oldest uh
living rainforest so they say my main
goal here is that the room has a private
plunge pool
like in White Lotus that guy who went
nuts I get it I totally get that
but we do we have a private pool I will
throw a fit
if there is not a private pool I do not
care how beautiful it is it does not
matter to me
we're going to get the Pavilion Suite
which is the best Suite in the
rainforest
this is how I want to enjoy the
rainforest I want to enjoy we have a
private Chef that is doing a four course
meal if it is a three-course meal I will
light Acres of that rainforest on fire
with a Marlboro Light myself I am paying
for luxury I am paying for luxury I do
not care do not sing me songs do not
tell me about the old ways of the
indigenous people I don't care about
unlocking their secrets it is of no
value to me okay unless they know how to
[ __ ] bid on a house in Calabasas and
get it and get it [ __ ] finally so I
stopped losing out to the Chinese I
don't need to know about their [ __ ]
you know how they made a uh you know a
flute out of a log I have no interest
so unless they can advise me how to beat
the Chinese in the Hills because I keep
losing then it's not about and again
does this make me sound like a defensive
American perhaps
but I don't think it does you're much
more into this [ __ ] than I am with the
with the nature and all this uh [ __ ]
right I want to see that little baby
monkey
you you like the koalas I wanted to see
the koalas you said koalas suck they do
suck they're not Showman
animals are supposed to jump up and down
and throw balls and ride jet skis and
we're paying money the thing's asleep
what if I slept on a stage for an hour
they'd be a riot the koalas are not
funny they're not interesting they have
no personality they're cute they have
they're they're they're they're like
actors that are just hot and they have
jobs because they're hot people like to
cause their cuddly they are vicious
nasty animals they're ungrateful people
move them off the roads to not get
killed and what do they do they make
that disgusting sound they
are ungrateful animals [ __ ] them get
them out of here yeah they're cute you
like little cute animals I like animals
that have careers
they put on a show you like that you
wanted to see the kangaroo much more
than I did I like the kangaroo that does
things it punches people and hops
it does things the koala does nothing
the guy like scratches its back it turns
around it gives us a brief look we take
a photo that's 50 bucks I could have
uploaded that
I could have copied and pasted that I
didn't have to drive there but you
really like little cute animals and
seeing things yeah I mean by the way you
briefly mentioned we're gonna get in a
swimming hole in the rainforest there's
a swimming hole yes is it safe I would
imagine there's no Crocs in a swimming
hole there's no snakes and stuff up
there well I don't know about that
foreign
but I assume the snakes that are there
work for the resort good
the animals should be working for the
resort
I want this is a resort experience I'm
not backpacking through the rainforest
to commune with the ancient Spirits I
have no interest in that if the
scrambled eggs aren't fluffy I'm going
to be loud I'm going to Sam Town's
coming we're going to smoke we're not
going to partake in any physical
strenuous activity if it bothers us even
to the slightest degree oh walk up that
hill you get to see a view [ __ ] off you
do it and take a photo of it show it to
me on your iPhone
the swimming hole Mossman Gorge I
imagine is safe I believe it's safe I
mean we already died once here in a
[ __ ] Riptide I know so a swimming
hole it's a nice little hole in the
water
where we will sit
and probably smoke cigarettes
and look at the wildlife
and if the what and I would I would like
if and again
again if this was like an island of Dr
moreau's situation where I put on a
white jacket and I have like a device
where if if the animals get too close
they have little uh uh collars around
their neck and I shocked them and they
can say that wouldn't be the worst thing
in the world I like that if there was a
[ __ ] playing a piano everyone hates
that movie but I don't
that to me is a is a fun vacation but we
must feel at all times Superior to this
ancient wisdom that really adds up to
nothing and if it added up to anything
they would have figured out how to make
a bridge it's what it is this is a
western show today I am proud of cities
I am proud of dating apps I am proud of
Starbucks I'm proud that people can
shove their [ __ ] in your mouth within
five minutes of meeting them on the
internet I am proud of civilization I'm
proud of real estate I'm proud of
bidding wars I'm proud of hollow uh
existence that has meant uh for all of
us to just keep busy consuming [ __ ] we
don't need I'm fans of hollow shallow
relationships that ultimately don't
matter and I'm hoping we can incorporate
that into this ancient spiritual
landscape of the rainforest because if
that was that good if these rainforests
matter that much
[ __ ] would be going on there
and they vilified the developers to try
to get into the rainfall I mean they
vilify these poor people developers that
try to put up luxury condos and luxury
hotels in the rainforest are vilified
Ben the logging companies they are
vilified they are creating jobs
all they want to do is take a few Acres
of the rainfall and I think we can spare
a few acres for a nice complex
but they're vilified and attacked
constantly it's a growing rainforest not
shrinking I read that it's growing but I
saw immediately on the daintree ice
cream website it says what are your
sustainable practices that's a big
question they get and they're committed
to preserving tropical North Queensland
Wildlife so people do get upset about
that these broke [ __ ] don't know how
to franchise they should be all over the
[ __ ] world they should be serving
this ice cream all over the [ __ ]
world but they don't know how to do it
because they're babbling about
sustainability how about this cut the
[ __ ] stop stop with these faggity
flavors like waddle seed and
[Music]
and start putting chunks of [ __ ] real
Brazilian coffee or whatever cocaine or
Australian Marmite or you know
I don't know I'm just saying what about
a what about a pint of ice cream with a
big Cadbury Cream Egg in the middle and
you call it Journey to the Center of the
Earth and you could you could have one
of those flavors you could use a you
could say it's like uh mango ice cream
or whatever you know but in the middle
of it there's a big Cadbury Creme Egg
and you could just just gnaw at it yeah
yeah so I understand that they're big
into the sustainability but I just don't
want to lose what do they call that
we're losing the what losing the there's
a there's a uh
there's a uh expression we're losing the
narrative losing the oh yeah losing the
narrative I don't think that's it we're
losing the thread I don't know but what
I mean is that I'm there to really enjoy
the ice cream and maybe give them some
advice on how to take their business to
the next level
you know again the the witness of the
world and the people that
like all animals want to live in the
wild that's completely untrue that's
completely untruck correct many dogs and
cats are very happy being domesticated I
would say the majority of them and I
think many animals could and would have
jobs if we're we were able to give them
jobs because hanging out all day has got
to be somewhat boring if we could if a
if a gorilla could work at State Farm
own a house
and have a wife I don't think he'd want
to be in the wilderness like some type
of monster
I'm going to ask these types of
questions when we are on the river
cruise
I was treated very coldly you know on
that Safari the other day when he's
talking about the rhino horns and I made
a very innocuous comment I said well
it's a good business
because it is I mean let's let's take
morality out of it for a second it's a
good business the Rhino horn business in
Africa right now is a phenomenal
business it is a phenomenal opportunity
to make 75
000 for a rhino horn
that is what the going rate is I think
it's I don't think it's maybe the
greatest thing to do
but I just made a comment
Chinese fentanyl good business don't do
it don't take it don't sell it but it's
a great business if you're just talking
money
so I'm just hoping this vacation
is everything that I like
luxury the appearance of nature
and
some time and some quiet to reflect
we're hearing a lot about crypto
everywhere crypto companies are
investing in stars like Tom Brady LeBron
James even dominated Super Bowl ads
spending Millions to get in front of
sports fans but some of these companies
had their website crash on the big day
or have poorly rated customer service
meanwhile Exodus is investing in making
crypto apps and build a world-class
customer support team and if you don't
you don't even have to support your
personal details like your mom's maiden
name to use it just download Exodus and
you're all set did you hear about Canada
authorizing financial institutions to
freeze people's accounts who are
suspected of supporting protesting
vaccine mandates they don't even have to
have proof they're just trying to kill
you so why would you get involved if
they're trying to kill you
are you going to keep your money under
your control or not get a crypto wallet
like Exodus you know the revolution is
coming the entire world is going to fall
apart we're going to be a stateless
society of a narco-capitalist running
everything on digital currency
there'll be small hovels for people to
live that haven't gotten on the crypto
wave but the rest of us will be like
crazy feudal Kings just enjoying our
crypto getting the best goods and
services brought directly to us but we
need to keep our crypto saved inflation
is insane right now things are getting
more expensive wages aren't going up and
the government keeps printing money to
give away to people who already have a
lot of it the traditional Financial
system is sinking it Bitcoin is the life
raft it's time to ditch your bank leave
traditional Finance behind and join the
financial Revolution Exodus is a crypto
app for your phone and computer that is
easy to use it supports over 150 crypto
assets looks great and as a world-class
customer support we're hearing about
crypto all over the place you need to
get involved the future is going to be
run entirely on crypto if you don't have
it you are going to live in some type of
Slum that is not what you want you're
not going to be able to get clean water
your children are going to have diseases
that make their face is ugly
go and download Exodus right now visit
exodus.com Tim to get started that's
exodus.com Tim to get started it takes
time to control your wealth get started
for free by downloading Exodus on mobile
and desktop exodus.com Tim it's a crypto
wallet for everyone no signup is
required download and you're ready to go
by visiting exodus.com Tim it's a great
way to store your crypto keep your
personal information saved and get ready
for the future because we're done with
this tour this tour started in September
of 2020.
at Vinnie Brands Stress Factory Comedy
Club where they had an outdoor tent it
was the first time I had done any stand
up in like six months or however long
because we got shut down in March
um it was pretty wild and the tour was
shut down twice
um for two surges of coven and
we kept doing bigger theaters and
filling bigger venues we've toured All
Over America we've done every city in
America we've done every
English-speaking country in the world
pretty much outside of maybe South
Africa but
I mean I don't know if you would call
that an English-speaking country
but we've done Dublin you know we've
done Ireland we've done Scotland we've
done London uh we've done the UK we've
done Australia we've gone everywhere
it's over it's time to hang it up
there's nothing left to do so this is a
nice way me you and Sam Talent have a
little vacation a little three-day jaunt
into the rainforest to kind of reflect
on how fun it has been uh the last
couple of days I mean the last couple of
years doing this it's been a lot and we
do apologize to a lot of the podcast
fans who love the video episodes we love
doing them too but it is very difficult
to do a video episode I'm not gonna do
it in a hotel room but the good news is
I will be back in my studio next week to
analyze all of the funny and fun stories
like the imminent nuclear war and uh the
Florida the gay people and Disney World
versus uh Ron DeSantis and uh the PTA or
whatever the hell we've been talking
about in our country for the last five
months and here's another thing I'll say
I don't want Putin to use a nuclear
weapon I'm going to make that
stipulation immediately but I will tell
you this
the Ukrainian war is getting so [ __ ]
boring
that if there is not
something
I'm no longer watching and I'm barely
gonna talk about it it's gotten like
covet
it doesn't seem dangerous there anymore
Boris Johnson's going Pelosi's going
they're all visiting with zelinski I
mean pretty soon my uh fat agent is
gonna have me and Keith doing a show it
doesn't seem that dangerous
so while I do not want
Vladimir Putin to use a nuclear weapon
in Ukraine
what I am saying
is that if this show
doesn't get
better if it doesn't have a new
storyline I'm no longer watching
what is small tactical nuclear weapon
would do
is it would give the story a little bit
more relevance I'm not saying you should
do it I'm against it
if it happened I would cover it more
it's not is it it's not worth it I mean
we do a great job covering it
it's but it's cost benefit and I don't
want the Ukraine to be nuked what I am
saying is I'm getting very bored what is
going on in the Ukraine now is it even
still happening well they had the
genocide as you know well
I don't know
but I believe you so lately Putin has
said on record if someone intends to
interfere in what is going on from the
outside they must know that constitutes
an unacceptable strategic threat to
Russia they must know that our response
to counter-strikes will be like that
[ __ ] has been saying that we've been
arming the Ukraine we've been funding
the Ukraine and yes he's got Hypersonic
missiles it could hit New York City but
we're a big [ __ ] country and we will
just we will just launch and Russia will
be over I believe this is the first time
he says you know we will use them like
if anything happens we will absolutely
class in our country wants nuclear war
you can't scare us they want a nuke us
they did this is not something that
they're even trying to avoid who are you
scaring with that
these people want a couple of mushroom
cloud they want that that way they can
flatten Russia I mean we will go crazy
if we are nuked uh so uh did you see the
news that broke uh this morning uh that
he is undergoing cancer operation yes so
Putin is undergoing cancer operations
well can I say something can I say
something yeah we I wish him well
I don't
and I don't
I'm not going to start wishing death on
people
thank you
well he has abdominal cancer and
Parkinson's disease that is what they're
reporting so it's a sudden answer you
know everybody's like well Russia's bad
to gay people is Ukraine great to gay
people where is this idea that the
Ukraine is like some like San Francisco
level of Tolerance there literally I
heard from somebody the other day who
dated a Ukrainian chick she said my
brothers I would just go beat up if they
saw a black person they go beat him up
that's literally what you said that was
literally a quote from her I'm not
making that up I'm against the war
Putin's a scumbag but let me just tell
you that is what I heard it's is it
hearsay maybe is it um what do you call
the anecdotal absolutely that is what I
heard
foreign
the idea that the Ukraine is like a
Bastion of Tolerance is untrue
neither is Russia
I don't really I'm just saying I'm
against War
what I am saying is that I'm I'm
incredibly bored
I'm incredibly bored with this well
they're sort of foreshadowing here that
there could be a change of Changing of
the Guard because poon's health problems
could deteriorate is what they're
speculating if it's going to be handed
off to spymaster protrusive
so that that could be a whole
interesting that could be a whole
different set of narratives right there
a new King in power
well that guy's even worse from what
I've read right that's what I've read
too yeah right so he's a real Bill de
Blasio
um this is him Nikolai
Patricia he's not gonna de-escalate
right
nobody named Nikolai is gonna come in
there and
so Putin is undergoing Cancer Treatments
yeah but apparently he has Parkinson's
too which I didn't know but those videos
have been going viral of him not really
he hasn't been able to really sit up
upright in his chair I'm sure you've
seen those of like he just doesn't look
well but as is anyone speculating that
that's poisoning from what you've heard
or is he just it's just coincidence no
one has speculated to me personally that
he's being poisoned okay
it's just interesting in terms of the
timeliness of it but perhaps but I do
think it's widely known that he has been
having Health struggles and I think that
that is unfortunate well
he will be going under surgery soon it
seems it'll be incapacitated during that
surgery so then there might be some type
of uh maybe a coup something might go
down over there nice
interesting
whatever I'm just saying I'm done I'm
done I donated 5 000 Bitcoin I wish
everyone well I hope they succeed I hope
they drive out the Invaders I hope they
uh set up a fun world for themselves I
don't that is not my concern my concern
is finally it's time to relax I have to
relax it's time for me to relax it's
time for me to relax it's time for me to
take a vacation I can't be concerned
with the nonsense
we have a horrible economy in this
country that is preventing people like
myself from going around the world and
abusing uh other people and that's wrong
the cost of fuel right now is preventing
fat Americans from getting on planes and
destroying whatever land mass they
happen to be in
it's not right we need to bring the cost
of things down it's true the inflation
is crazy the interest rates are spiking
people want to buy homes and if people
cannot buy a home that will eventually
uh collapse on top of them and kill them
metaphorically not even literally but I
mean you know that's what it's about and
so now why you and your wife should
start thinking about in the future
buying a home
oh I've been looking all over the place
you know what I mean to have a home to
have something that you have to pay for
every month whether you enjoy it or like
it or not to just have that weight to
have that debt debt is beautiful that's
the closest you'll ever get to God
the closest you'll ever get to God is
dead
because we owe a debt when we come into
the world we're owed to debt you owe a
debt for just living so the way to
glorify God and to glorify that debt
that you owe is to take on more debt
more debt and that weight of the debt
that crushing weight holding that up
every day it's Sisyphus with the you
know that is important so I think it's
very important for you
and that's why I'm very excited to get
back to America
expressvpn everybody needs a VPN right
now it's an app that prevents your phone
carrier from being able to see the sites
you visit and sell them to third parties
all it takes is one tap of a button and
all of your network data gets encrypted
and rerouted through expressvpn secure
servers for ultimate privacy not only
does it Shield your web browsing
expressvpn protects all of your
networked data so you can stay private
even when using your favorite apps
whether you're an iPhone Android or even
tablet user expressvpn works on all your
devices the best part is one
subscription can be used up to five
devices at the same time I have my whole
family using expressvpn too when your
phone carrier tracks you that's a gross
invasion of privacy you can either keep
letting them cash in on you or visit
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon to get the
same VPN I use take back your online
privacy today and use my link to get
three months free
that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com Tim Dillon three
months free
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon I love bespoke
post because I like to gift people
things I like to give gifts but I also
love to give things that are unique and
interesting and box of awesome is
amazing bespoke post partners with small
businesses and emerging Brands to bring
you the unique the most unique Goods
every month I love box of awesome okay
no matter what you have going on this
season box of awesome has you covered
from camping gear Essentials to cookout
to must haves like hot sauces and
barbecue rubs box of awesome has
collections for every part of your life
to get started take the quiz at
boxofawesome.com your answers will help
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every single
month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued around
seventy dollars but you only pay a
fraction of that price plus with each
box of awesome you're supporting small
business 90 of everything that comes in
your box of awesome is from a small up
and coming brand it's free to sign up
and you can skip a month month or cancel
any time get 20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter the code Tim
Dillon at checkout that's box of
awesome.com Tim Dylan at checkout you
get 20 off your first box again this is
great for you it's great to give as a
gift you can send somebody that's going
off to college you can get them a cool
box every single month somebody that's
moving to a new city it's really really
cool
again uh depending on what they're into
they can get gadgets they can get
grooming utensils they can get
everything
um and I'm telling you right now it's
really cool that all these small
businesses are providing the stuff for
box of awesome like the American
barbecue rub in the carnivore box is
made by the Great American spice Co in
Rockford uh Mississippi the Damascus
steel knife is made by Buck bear knives
located in Pennsylvania the god hook
knife in the trail box is made by Titan
International located in Illinois that
would be great for people that are into
fishing so that's what I love about box
of awesome they're helping small
businesses Thrive and it's a great way
to not only gift yourself something but
potentially gifted to somebody else
that's box of awesome.com slash Tim
Dylan the code is Tim Dillon for 20 off
and next week we're going to do a
special of summer vacation spots for
uh the poor because a lot of people
right now are [ __ ] and they need to
know where they can go on a vacation and
enjoy themselves we are going to suggest
10
summer vacation spots it's going to be a
very big episode it's our first episode
from the studio get excited and I want
you to watch this with your family
because it's going to be 10 vacation
spots that you can go to even though
your lives are horrible
even though you have a horrible life
that has been destroyed by forces you
can barely understand you should be able
to shimmy your diseased fat ass down to
some type of swimming hole or Crick and
go in there you should be able to eat a
hot dog you should be able to watch
Nikki glaser's new show on eating
you should be able to enjoy the summer
you should enjoy the summer and we have
got 10 spots that are going to be
perfect
at
we're actually going to try to do it I
actually thought we're going to do a bit
where we were going to say like the
Hamptons Nantucket places like that we
are actually not going to do that we I
thought I thought differently because we
were going to do a bit where I would get
on and go uh an average uh Hampton's
rental in the summer would be 50
000 a month or a hundred thousand a
month and it was the whole big joke was
going to be that all of the nice places
in America had you'd been priced out of
that was going to be the bit but I think
that's number one you could kind of see
it coming number two it's cruel we are
actually going to literally scour this
earth like where did you grow up going
to Vacation uh like Port Aransas and
stuff like that that's right we're going
there what is it Padre Padre Island we
are going to showcase
the top 10 areas that you can I want you
to take a family trip for under twelve
hundred dollars
I want you to take a family trip for
almost no money
and it's you know it's not going to be
Nantucket it's not going to be the Four
Seasons in Maui but we're going to
tell you 10 places that you can take
your disgusting family so that they can
remember because we it's about creating
the memories for the children
and we're going to we are going to
really
scour the country and I'm excited
because what is what is it Port Aransas
what is it uh South Padre Island and
what is that it's just you know there's
oil factories and needles and uh the
water's very gross have you swam in the
Gulf of Texas I have never gone near it
the Gulf of Mexico not even once
well it's it's brown so it's like the
color of Lake water it's kind of like
this we're looking at the Brisbane uh
River a little bit but you can swim in
it yeah
and I bet there are tacos
right there's uh there's like uh I
remember we had a lot of imitation crab
meat that's right which is pollock and
Pollock is not bad you go to the
supermarket on Padre Island sign me up
so what you do is you go to like you get
the really cheap crab or imitation crab
meat you go back to your hotel get some
hellmanns
get helmets or you boil it and then you
again you get a thing of butter and boil
the butter and then you dip your hands
[ __ ] yeah not bad
not bad I think we were watching a
Project Runway on the TV it was a fun
vacation that's that was an odd turn why
you're watching your Christian families
eating Pollock and Watching Project run
my mother loved the show in the
mid-2000s interesting Heidi Klum was
great I loved that show
Tim Gunn was phenomenal yeah that Nazi
[ __ ]
now I'm just saying I'm excited because
there are all kinds of areas that are
that are for you know people that are
struggling and we don't remember them
yeah
we don't remember these people and
they're ignored in our society and I'm
against that but what I can do what we
can do is put out
a list of 10 places that maybe are more
affordable uh because they are the sites
of the ecological disasters
or they've been linked to higher rates
they've been linked to higher rates of
cancer
or there is maybe some violence in and
or near the area so you got to be alert
you just got to be alert
for example I'm just going to throw if
you want to take a trip how about Port
Moresby in Papua New Guinea
now Port Moresby Papua New Guinea is a
tropical destination for the Discerning
World Traveler
now 80 of the women that live in Port
Moresby are
subject to sexual assault and that is
not good
and there are many crimes committed
against tourists involving Bush knives
machetes or things like that that being
said
I think it can be an affordable
destination for a family
the flight will be expensive can you
read some statistics about Port Moresby
Papua New Guinea yes this is uh this is
very high some of the highest in the
world if not the highest it looks what
that well the level of crime is insane
in Portmore Street yes but listen
I don't focus on negatives
I'm trying to alert people okay to it
because the flights are going to be
expensive but once you go there it gets
real cheap okay so this is uh I'm on
numbio.com which does statistics of
crime in the world it looks like uh so
we have crime and Port Moresby Papua New
Guinea right here we go here we go okay
uh so you understand how crime index
Works no I don't so if something is uh
like uh the crime index is 82.15 here uh
so that is your chance so it's the scale
out of every hundred people it's the
scale of zero or a hundred for Value
since it's easy to read for users it
generates a current index
uh uses data up to 36 months old
trying to figure out what this means
exactly because I thought you would does
crime ruin a vacation or is it a fun
story
that's another great point
would a crime being committed against
you ruin the entire vacation or would it
be a fun story to look back on years
later and say
we watched
Our Father gets stripped naked in the
middle of the street and robbed
many families don't even like each other
so this idea that violent crime is going
to turn off everybody isn't true oh so
it means per 1000 people so per 1000
people 100 of them or 80 something are
getting it yeah so uh worries home
broken and things stolen 77 so 77 out of
a thousand people and a period of three
years have got their home broken into
and things but right but but again if
you're a traveler and you're staying at
the Hilton Port Moresby and you are just
you keep to yourself and you're smart
um I think it'll be fine uh you will be
a victim of a violent crime uh such as
assault or armed robbery it's a 84 out
of a thousand
hey I don't think it's that bad
I really don't
uh uh being subject to physical attack
because of your skin color or ethnic
origin gender or religion 71 out of a
thousand
hey
not bad
not bad to me
get the kids on the plane
tell us about some of the hotels there's
a Hilton oh is there okay can we call
the Hilton Port Moresby right now
can we call the Hilton Port Moresby
right now on my phone can't we do it my
phone's right over there can we get them
on the phone because I want to take I
have a family and we're trying to take a
trip to Port Morris Bay the most violent
city on Earth from what they say but
they've never been to you know America
can we I'd like you to do it through
WhatsApp or whatever
let's get these people on the phone do
they speak English
I think they will because it's an
international uh you know chain Hilton
okay this might be the first time they
get a call from uh an LA number maybe I
don't think so or Beverly Hills number
possibly let's see here I don't think so
I bet there's a lot of directors actors
producers that want to go over there and
whack people with machetes
they probably have a tour for people
that want to go over there take a break
from the California Sun and go hack
people with bush knives
okay I'm calling the Hilton right now
I watched the whole thing the other day
where it's like hostile that movie with
Eli Roth that's true
in Port Moresby no in other places like
people just go and kill people in in you
know
okay that's the that's the number
looks like a good location
is kind of pretty on the Google Images
here why aren't they answering
how are you is this the Hilton in Port
Moresby
yes sir thank you so much I'm trying to
come there with my family for a summer
vacation but we've heard that the Port
Moresby is very dangerous is that true
all right it's it's a good place
but
if if they said you have to just
um just to be on transport
right so if I go there with my family is
it a nice place where we can walk around
or is there a chance that there'll be a
problem
um in the hotel services
well let's say we left the hotel
all right dear so
I don't think it's safe
to leave the hotel
but if we if we stayed at the hotel is
nice you have a pool
do you have in-room dining
room dining and we have a complimentary
shuttle to the mall
Oh what now what is that
okay so as long as we as long as we stay
in our hotel and go to the pool and
don't leave the hotel for any reason you
think we'll be fine
I guess that um we have the guts here so
the hotel is safe because there are
guards but now if we left the hotel
that's where we might run into uh a real
problem
yes so it depends on where you want to
go
right
what are the attractions in what are
like the attractions in the area
all right we we have the national museum
as well as the Botanical Gardens the
nature box we can organize a taxi for
you or we can organize Black Swan VIP
transposers let me stay through this
right so if we're in yes if we're in the
taxi on the way to the Botanical Garden
we'll probably be safe
and the plate number so we keep checking
that's good so that makes me feel better
you'll keep track of the the plate
number on the taxi
well so we only we only get Comfort
taxes those are the reliable taxis
it was mostly right but it it's not the
type of place where we would we would
want to just go walk around
okay but the in-room dining is good is
it tasty
yes it's Thursday it's 24 hours so you
can order
well I like that well I'm you've sold me
because the hotel has guards around it
and you can order the food at uh anytime
you want
well it sounds good yes
because we also have the copper pot
that's on ground levels this stretch
from level one and we also have the Momo
restaurant it's um it's from Wednesday
to Saturday it local traditional food
right and it's just our only issue is
that if we were to leave the hotel for
any reason there's a chance we could get
attacked by a machete
all right yeah so we can arrange Tech
like transport for you if you want to go
somewhere
right because that's the whole thing
do do you give out for the people that
are staying in the hotel will you give
them would you give us machetes so we
could at least defend ourselves
would you give us machetes so that we
could defend ourselves on the street
okay
all right well listen that you've sold
me on this and I really appreciate all
of your help thank you I'm very excited
about my trip
all right and hopefully we see you soon
here at Hilton yes I'm very excited
about it sounds like
it sounds lovely
all right thank you so much thank you
hold on give me let me let me
what
what
good how are you what's going on
well we extended till 12 last night
yeah
yeah we extended uh till 12. the the
reception
thank you very much
enough already what was that about I
don't know she wants us out of here but
that Port Moresby sounds lovely
the Hilton looks that's the nicest
Hilton I've ever seen
it's gray look at that it's lovely
that's CGI
but it's nice
what's the problem that woman sounded
like she was pretty um you know she
sounded uh pretty um
hopeful about our prospects the only
thing is you can't leave the hotel right
and if you leave the hotel they will
arrange a specific taxi for you to take
you to your murder
well the these are the types of things
that we're going to do next week we're
very excited about this because we have
to get realistic you're not going you're
not gonna go to Anguilla you know what I
mean you're just not so what you're
gonna do is get realistic and there's
gonna have to be certain things that you
just [ __ ] live with if you want to
enjoy a nice vacation
in Port Moresby
you think that's CGI because look how
nice that looks
I believe it is CGI yes
but God loved that woman
and I'm very excited about it and if I
had a family I would take them there
over Padre Island
where would you stay in Padre Island oh
just uh they have motels
they have motels along the beach there
right yeah yeah you know what's nice
Delaware
because they have some beaches and some
college kids and you can go cheat on
your wife with a college girl
while your wife feeds your fat kids
clams
you could go give a college girl a
thousand dollars to hop on a dick
is there something wrong with that my
podcast without Baldwin came out do
people like it are the reviews good or
are they not uh it seems like people are
uh excited about it it looks like it was
edited down but I have no problem with
that
yeah I mean a lot of people do podcasts
and then edit them down
for reasons who knows yeah who knows and
that's good
right you know these times when you're
so into what you're doing and you can't
think about anything else at times and
you're most focused and productive
psychologists call that feeling that
feeling of being in the zone Flow State
Alpha Brain from on it is the ultimate
way to get there a world-renowned
nootropic supplement with over 1 million
bottles sold Alpha Brain promotes
cognitive functions including memory
mental speed and focus it can help you
remember names heroin on complex tasks
and think more clearly under stressed
comedian and podcaster Joe Rogan says he
feels it helps him form better sentences
when he's talking Alpha Brain contains
amino acids and plant compounds that
promote the brain's release of alpha
waves which are associated with greater
creativity and productivity at the same
time it supports neurotransmitters
chemicals that relay information in and
from the brain If coffee and energy
drinks make you jittery you can rest
easy knowing that Alpha Brain is
caffeine free but if for any reason you
don't like Alpha Brain you can get your
money back just give us two weeks if at
that point you don't feel like Alpha
Brain is a fit for you just tell us why
and we'll refund you your money on the
spot no return necessary save 10 percent
on your order by going to onnit.com Tim
I love it I use it how do you think I'm
so smart on the goddamn show it's a
daily nootropic it promotes focus and
concentration supports cognitive
function great for helping you get into
that flow state that feeling of being in
the zone it sold over a million bottles
it's got a money back guarantee
I'm telling you right now you are gonna
love Alpha Brain it helps you maintain
and support and promote and Aid and
assist and encourage your mental well
being your ability to function do it on
it.com slash Tim
everybody's a watch guy now you got to
become a watch guy or a watch gal or a
watch non-binary Person Ventura
Collective is a great uh thing okay I
love Ventura it's a premium Lifestyle
brand in San Diego carrying incredible
eyewear watches much more if you don't
know them yet there's no better time to
check in on them they just released the
Argo automatic a collector quality dive
watch you need to check out guys get
Ventura watches it's a great company
they have all kinds of things in
addition to watches they have eyewear
they have other things everybody's doing
watches right now they are modern
they're ethical they're creating premium
lifestyle accessories for those devoted
to growth in all aspects of their life
Health Wellness Community Etc I'm
telling you eye-catching modern designs
to go with any outfit or style perfect
for a day in the office or date night
products are made to last with the
quality that you can feel the Argo named
after the mythological Greek ship
crafted by the gods Perfect Blend form
function style utility five colorways
high-powered citizen Miota 901 automatic
movement fluted unidirectional rotating
bezel Swiss Loom hands divers clasp we
get that all online shopping can be
frustrating will this fit will it really
look like this will it be broken in a
week Ventura's five-year guarantee and a
365 day free return policy has you
covered but you don't need to take my
word for it with over thirty thousand
five star reviews featured in Forbes
Business Insider Newsweek just to name a
few Ventura offers you a shopping
experience you can trust I love vincero
the Argo is my favorite I'm telling you
right now it's a great promotion if you
go to v i n c e r o collective.com
forward slash Tim Dillon that's
vincerocollective.com forward slash Tim
Dylan you can get 15 off in free
shipping to our listeners with code Tim
Dillon that's 15 off and free shipping
to our listeners with code Tim Dillon at
v i n c e r o collective.com forward
slash Tim Dylan I I wear a venture our
watches and I love them are you excited
about this rainforest trip uh I'm a
little you really don't seem excited no
no you tried to get out of it like nine
times no no no no no no I'm I'm excited
about it I'm scared of a couple things
the private plane well one I'm scared of
a private plane so I read statistics
this morning and looked into it they're
not good they're not great but that's
the same thing with Port Moresby
you heard the woman just stay in your
room
don't go looking for a problem
statistics if you start reading
statistics you'll be off Twitter right
keep going uh second thing is this is a
wild Excursion this whole Australian
trip and I feel like nature is trying to
kill us around every corner yes but
that's why I am telling you right now
when they say that people are more
powerful than nature that's untrue
that's untrue Ben
that's untrue the ocean sucked us out
into the sea the ocean owns nothing
the ocean what's the market cap on the
ocean
I'm not worried about nature
I'm worried about nurture the people
nature doesn't scare me
they have Anti-Venom
I don't even think these animals are
dangerous in the rainforest the tree
kangaroo
is it true you can be allergic to
anti-venom when they give it to you and
then you find out I don't know
uh so there are dangerous creatures in
the
in the area do you want me to read them
all yeah tell me what the dangerous
creatures in the area are
there's the oraconda or a Condi
jellyfish
the box jellyfish the blue ringed
octopus that'll kill you the blue ring
the stone fish yes that'll kill you uh
crocodiles that that'll they'll do it
and there are sharks in the area
uh we're moving on to snakes now there's
the red belly black snake
uh the brown snake the tiger snake the
Death Adder
and the typing
uh arachnids ready for arachnids
this one will affect you more than me
even though I've been bit by a brown
recluse uh you have the paralysis tick
okay a funnel web spider that's right
and you have a red back spider right uh
those are your enemies in the daintree
rate but isn't the real danger
inequality
like isn't that the real problem isn't
that the underlying issue here
isn't that the real issue if we're gonna
look at you know
would the blue ringed octopus be nearly
as dangerous
if it could work
why are you so worried about these
things
uh well like as soon as we got here uh
we the the nature tried to take our own
lives yeah they tried to take us back
into the Earth where we die and then
it's eventually be Stardust once again
like it wants us to return
back into its soil I'll never be
Stardust
I'll be another kind of dust
but that's a real that's some Joni
Mitchell song we're not going to be
Stardust
we might be star [ __ ]
whew but nature is trying to kill you
all the time because nature does not
like winners
and we've won you think Alec Baldwin's
afraid of nature Ben
do you think a guy like that gives a
[ __ ]
another guy on that set got bit by a
brown recluse spider and almost lost his
arm
but Alec Baldwin did not you know why
because Alec Baldwin doesn't walk around
like a [ __ ]
I think you make way too much out of
nature you got to show nature you're the
boss you're the boss
I don't even know that we have to leave
our room
we have floor-to-ceiling Windows why do
we have to leave
you just look at it from the outside
can you calm me down with the private
plan thing a little bit
yes
there's a 50 chance we'll be okay
we've got some drunk Australian up there
who's [ __ ] lazy and we're on some
piece of [ __ ] playing
drive going through the rainforest
I feel fine
I mean I can't wait to see because the
business uh manager is hooking this up I
can't wait to see what this thing is
going to look like when we can't have us
die he needs us to keep earning money
that's true he's going to do the right
thing this is the one thing that I have
faith in him because he can't have us
die we make money so he wants to Keep Us
Alive at all costs
I think we'll be fine
okay I think we'll be fine we're flying
a private plane with a drunk into the
rainforest
I don't think it's a big deal I really
don't
and if you die you die you've already
accomplished a lot
I mean I I don't think you have to be
your wife will bounce back she'll marry
your brother no
no why why deny them that happiness
I'm just saying
if it is Our Fate to careen down
and die in the Australian Outback in a
plane crash and be eaten by animals if
that is Our Fate it is Our Fate it's not
a big deal
you know I read at one comforting
statistic yeah is that you survive 95 of
playing uh malfunctions or crashes is
that true that is absolutely untrue oh
God I didn't think it was but I read it
I don't know where you read that
that is absolutely it is completely made
up okay that is a completely pretend
statistic that I've never heard in my
life
I'm just saying man you should relax
we're going into a place where there are
deadly people but nothing's more deadly
than the white man the white American
male
we've got red blood in our veins we
don't give a [ __ ]
I'm telling you right now these things
can only kill you if you let them in
your head Ben yeah maybe you're right
maybe you're right I'm telling you
they're scared of us those animals are
scared of us they're scared of us
building cities and making them get jobs
they're scared of competition they're
scared of being outed as [ __ ]
we've got nuclear weapons we've got Amy
Schumer we've got it all we've got big
Ukrainian flags flying All Over Texas
we've got the Machinery of death we've
got secret societies we've got
International pedophile Cults we've got
organ trading and human trafficking
we've got everything we've got war and
violence and Chaos we've got media
Empires International lifestyle Brands
we've got influencers and tick-tockers
we've got mansions with square footage
and infinity pools we've got Bridges
we've got cruise liners where fat people
take tours of shitholes we've got
everything we've got politicians on the
take we've invented bribery extortion
corruption we murder for the sake of it
for fun we've got gangs both National
and international we've got malicious
we've got religion we've got all kinds
of things crazy uh pedophile priests and
pastors marrying 16 year olds we've got
it all we've got private prisons we've
got hospitals it'll take your organs
right before you're about to go and sell
them to someone else we are Humanity we
are what saved this planet we are what
made it special we've got amusement
parks where people die on the rise
because we don't do safety checks we've
got electric cars that go really fast
and we've even got Elon Musk
safeguarding Twitter we're okay we're
good
the Sharks and the octopuses and all of
this [ __ ] they will never pose even
a scintilla of the threat that Humanity
does
we have one we have dominated go into
the rainforest with that mentality
look at every natural beautiful thing
and go this would look a hell of a lot
better lined with Four Seasons Resorts
condos Pokeball places amusement parks
it's our planet for the taking Ben it's
not for the animals anymore
it's not for the animals Whitney
Cummings can say whatever she wants she
can rescue dogs she can jerk off horses
she can do whatever she wants but at the
end of the day you know what happens
you know who really wins US
the human because we can reason
we've made this a beautiful place where
everyone is happy that's the most
important thing you have to remember
we've given people the gift of gambling
the gift of of chance
we've got the Barstool Sports Playbook
you think I'm afraid of a shark we've
got Dave Portnoy
we've got it all
I'm not afraid of nature
it's been there 180 million years and
it's done nothing it's done [ __ ] it just
sits there and lives nothing is more
boring than life nothing
so you have to go into that area with
that attitude that's the attitude that
pushes civilization forward that's the
attitude that drives all Innovation
that's the attitude stop worrying about
the animals the fauna the Flora the
plants the diseases all of that the
weather it's all irrelevant you can beat
it you can beat it all with one of those
uh uh ice cream cones that looks like a
fish
do you see do you feel better now yeah I
feel better
thank you all you need is your
confidence you need to have the
confidence of a white man abroad
and you don't have it that's what I'm
worried about if I worry too much I'm
going to create something out of the
worry rather than that's exactly right
because nature might [ __ ] with you
because you respect it
people [ __ ] that up
they start respecting the thing that
wants them dead I don't respect nature I
respect the Mandarin Oriental
I respect tea service I respect the
Beverly Hills Hotel
I respect 150 million dollar property in
Malibu I respect boats
I barely respect people I just like the
things they create so I would not get
too lost in this okay
it's not a big deal it's really not a
big deal you've already won
you've already dominated these things
out here can't hurt you they can only
hurt you in your mind
that's the reality
that's the way you have to think
because that woman says well don't leave
your room in Port Moresby don't leave
your room she's afraid but is she afraid
of the snakes and the spiders is she
afraid of sharks are you not leaving
your room because of sharks
are sharks dragging you out of the car
with the machete no the only things you
ever have to fear is really people you
have to fear people and you have to fear
boredom
you know
that's why the best thing that Vladimir
Putin could do when he wakes up from his
cancer coma is launched a massive
nuclear strike
to remind people that we're still the
boss on this goddamn planet
we're the boss
and if Vladimir if we have to have a
nuclear war that involves several
Nations and destroys the lives of
millions or billions of people
to just show everybody that we're back
baby
this pandemic sidelined us for a little
bit but we're back we got way into
nature with this pandemic oh the
pandemic there's forces that are out of
our control
no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no we need to
come back we need to come back with a
nuclear war to just show people that we
don't give a [ __ ]
that's the most important thing
so I think you'll really enjoy the trip
uh I think I'll really enjoy it I think
Sam Talent will enjoy it
the most important thing to remember is
that statistically you're more likely to
get killed any other way than buy a
shark or a blue ringed octopus really
you know you're you're more likely to
get killed anywhere
so again I would just
relax calm down you know and stop
obsessing about things that are
irrelevant you know we're staying in a
high-end Hotel this is a high-end Resort
they've gone to all of they've gone to
all the trouble to colonize nature and
sell it to us
let's buy it
good luck everyone